neue rechtsextreme droh-mails die affäre
in der hessischen polizei leitet sich
aus der polizeipräsidenten tritt zurück
frankreich feiert den vierzehnter juli
bei der zeremonie steht in diesem jahr
der kampf gegen die korona pandemie
mittelpunkt und diskussion um
lieferketten gesetz wenn deutsche firmen
im ausland produzieren lassen dann
sollen sie auch dort für soziale
mindeststandards
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wir
auch norbert leben und für den sport ein
sogenannter von mir
wir beginnen mit der polizeiaffäre in
hessen die immer weitere kreise zieht
und beunruhigende fragen aufwirft wer
steckt hinter den todesdrohungen und
frauen die sich gegen rechtsextremismus
engagieren
wer hat dafür daten aus polizeicomputer
besorgt gibt es ein rechtsextremes
netzwerk in der hessischen polizei
heute kam es zu einem ersten rücktritt
und es wurde bekannt dass eine weitere
frau bedroht wird stefan schlosser sie
hat schon viele hassbotschaften und
todesdrohungen erhalten die berliner
kabarettistin ii die beide bereits im
märz letzten jahres sollen ihre
persönlichen daten von einem wiesbadener
polizei computer abgefragt worden sein
erfahren hat sie das von einem
journalisten warum muss ich so was aus
der presse erfahren warum wird mir da
durch bescheid gesagt also es ist nicht
mehr nachvollziehbar und ich kannten
nicht mehr einschätzen
also ich fühle mich nicht sehr beschützt
in dieser situation von der polizei weil
sie auch nicht mit mir kommunizieren
damit sind es schon drei bekannte fälle
von prominenten bei denen daten von
hessischen polizeirevieren ohne
dienstlichen grund abgefragt worden sind
zuerst bei der frankfurter
rechtsanwältin sedat yildiz vor zwei
jahren in diesem jahr bei der
fraktionsvorsitzende der hessischen
linkspartei janine wissler
darüber hat der landespolizeipräsident
udo münch dem minister erst nach monaten
informiert heute die konsequenz herr
münch und ich sind uns absolut einig
dass eine derart heraus derart
herausragende information sowohl für die
ermittlungen als auch für das für die
politische bewertung dieser drohungen
unmittelbar hätte erfolgen müssen
daher hat mich landespolizeipräsident
udo münch um seine versetzung in den
einstweiligen ruhestand gebeten
für die opposition ist der
landespolizeipräsident nur ein
bauernopfer
ein innenminister der die probleme nicht
löst seit zwei jahren keine ergebnisse
wegen der droh mails ist offensichtlich
der falsche und deswegen haben wir zur
arbeit dieses innenministers kein
vertrauen mehr und wir bezweifeln dass
der innenminister der richtige mann
an der stelle des innenministers ist in
einer sondersitzung im landtag muss der
minister kommende woche rede und antwort
stehen
frankreich kehrte heute am
nationalfeiertag die menschen die das
land durch die korona krise gebracht
haben einige krankenhaus und
pflegekräfte gehörten zu den wenigen die
bei den feierlichkeiten dabei sein
durften
der vierzehnte juli in corona zeiten
leerer chance ließ und nur eine kleine
zeremonie
eigentlich sind in frankreich an diesem
tag zehntausende auf den straßen
doch diesmal ist alles anders gewesen
aus paris christel haß am ende kommen
die pflegekräfte auf die plaza la
concorde und nehmen aufstellung neben
den soldaten
es sind ergreifende minuten
[Applaus]
dieser nationalfeiertag ist anders als
die anderen
es gibt keine zuschauer die ceremonies
klein und auf die plastik concorde
beschränkt es geht nicht um militärische
größe sondern um den dank der nation an
alle corona helfer an diesen vierzehnter
juli hat die armee bewusst den pflegern
die hauptrolle überlassen und den
männern und frauen die sich für uns
eingesetzt haben und uns von kogit 19
geschützt haben
vier europäische staaten werden
besonders für ihre unterstützung
gewürdigt auch deutschland sie hatten
schwer kranke patienten aus frankreich
aufgenommen
einer der ehrengäste gesundheitsminister
sparen wir haben sogar noch unsere
nachbarn helfen können und das ist genau
das was europäische verbundenheit heraus
macht ein nationalfeiertag an dem
präsident makro auch ein signal setzen
will ein signal der zuversicht er
kündigt 100 milliarden euro schweres
konjunkturprogramm an
doch die kritiker sind nur ein paar
straßen weiter rund 3000 menschen
pflegekräfte und ärzte aber auch geld
westen protestieren gegen macros politik
für den präsidenten ist es ein wichtiger
tag um vertrauen zurückzugewinnen
er muss die wirtschaftskrise schnell
lösen denn nach gronau rechnet
frankreich mit einer million arbeitslose
mehr
und das kann zu sozialen spannungen
führen
heute aber stehen dank und anerkennung
im vordergrund frankreich verneigt sich
vor den helden der korona krise es geht
um extrem viel geld beim eu sondergipfel
ende dieser woche das geplante 750
milliarden schwere paket gegen die
korona krise ist umstritten
ein kompromiss wird dringend gesucht
gestern war italiens ministerpräsident
konnte zu gast bei der kanzlerin im
moment ist spaniens regierungschef
sanchez spanien und italien wären
hauptempfänger der eu hilfen
besonders strittig ist die frage ob die
gelder als kredit oder zuschuss fließen
sollen und wie kontrolliert wird wofür
die hilfsgelder ausgegeben werden
vor dem treffen mit pedro sanchez
verbrachte die bundeskanzlerin den
halben tag bei markus söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident hatte
sie zu einer kabinettssitzung ins
prunkvolle schloss herrenchiemsee
eingeladen
dass die kanzlerin kam und dem derzeit
so populären csu mann soviel zeit
widmete befeuert die dauer-debatte um
ihre nachfolge
alexander pohl berichtet die kutschfahrt
von herrenchiemsee
bilder wie diese wissen angela merkel
und markus söder für sich zu nutzen
bei der bekämpfung der korona krise
verfolgen beide einen vorsichtigen
öffnungskurs auch heute ziehen merkel
und söder an einem strang und sprechen
sich für lokale ausreisesperre aus
corona hot spots aus so könne die
ausbreitung der krankheit auf andere
bundesländer am besten vermieden werden
ich finde es ist ein teils ein vorschlag
den man diskutieren sollte und für den
ich werben würde ein wichtiges thema
heute der hunderte milliarden euro
schwere eu wiederaufbau vor
hier ist es vor allem die csu die ihre
positionen etwa beim thema
staatsverschuldung neu bestimmen muss
auf neue fragen über die gleichen alten
antworten zu geben ist ein fehler
deswegen muss man auch manchmal dort
hohe summen um die es jetzt bei den
rettungspaketen gehen kann über den
schatten springen in einer anderen frage
springt söder nicht noch nicht das thema
der kanzlerkandidatur war heute auch am
chiemsee präsent für diesen köder fan
ist die sache entschieden der csu-chef
aber weicht
ganz schlecht lesen ist verdeckt da ist
ja nett aber es geht der erstens geht es
nicht darum auch und sie sehen aber mein
platz ist hier in bayern
und was sagt angela merkel nicht viel
dass ich sozusagen nicht mit der frage
wer wird mein nachfolger eine ich mir
eine besondere zurückhaltung auferlegen
kann nur sagen bayern hat einen guten
ministerpräsidenten der sich am ende
wohl alle optionen offen hält
also schack unterleib energy die
kanzlerin will sich nicht zu ihrer
nachfolge äußern aber ihr dürfte ja
bewusst sein welche signale sie mit
diesen bildern sind
wer so lange in der politik ist wie
angela merkel muss um die macht solcher
bilder wissen und dann stellt sich
natürlich die frage warum nimmt sie
diesen termin war der die spekulationen
um die ambitionen von markus söder und
um die chancen von markus söder auf eine
kanzlerkandidatur für die union weiter
anfachen muss zumal das ganze das
gegenteil von dem bewirkt was die
derzeitige parteivorsitzende der cdu
sich eigentlich letzte woche noch
gewünscht hat nämlich dass das thema
kanzlerkandidatur in der sommerpause
möglichst keine rolle spielt für markus
söder war das in jedem fall ein geschenk
heute er hat einen termin bekommen
voller lob und einigkeit die offiziellen
kandidaten für den parteivorsitz der cdu
und dann möglicherweise auch eine
kanzlerkandidatur würden sich um einen
solchen termin wohl noch bemühen müssen
die kanzlerin hat heute gesagt andere
ministerpräsidenten besucht sie auch
gerne wenn sie eingeladen wird das
trifft front bei den kandidaten nur auf
einen zu
nämlich herr laschet und ob der diese
einladung ausspricht muss man noch sehen
er wäre dann nämlich nur der zweite im
rennen
danke nach berlin schauen wir auf die
korona entwicklung in deutschland seit
beginn der pandemie haben sich
mittlerweile mehr als 200.000 menschen
angesteckt davon gelten mehr als 92
prozent als genesen 9077 menschen sind
in verbindung mit profit 19 gestorben
die zahl der neuinfektionen ist
rückläufig
im schnitt der vergangenen woche haben
sich täglich 300 menschen neu mit dem
virus infiziert
corona und die usa da gerät jeden tag
die lage etwas weiter außer kontrolle im
moment besonders in kalifornien
was bemerkenswert es galt doch der
bevölkerungsreichste us-bundesstaat
lange als musterschüler im kampf gegen
das virus
als einer der ersten hatte er ein
ausgangsverbot und zunächst nur wenige
fälle aber dann wurde offenbar viel zu
früh gelockert denn die zahlen
explodierten
und so gilt jetzt kommando zurück peter
jäger für fast drei monate hatte jessica
ließ ihren friseursalon in sacramento
dicht machen müssen dann kamen
lockerungen im juni das geschäft lief
wieder
nun aber muss sie erneut schließen die
vorerst letzte kundin sitzt auf dem
stuhl
das zerrt an den nerven hieraus hin und
her ist mental und emotional wirklich
schlimm für uns ich bin gerade einfach
schockiert friseure fitnessstudios
kirchen schließen erneut in den bezirken
in dem das corona virus besonders bietet
und im gesamten bundesstaat sind
innenräume von bars und restaurants
wieder dicht getrunken werden darf nur
noch draußen
das ist unglücklich vielen geschäften
geht es schon schlecht vor allem denen
die kein außenbereich anbieten können
aber ich verstehe schon das risiko in
geschlossenen räumen ist einfach zu groß
kalifornien hatte seine scharfen regeln
früh wieder gelockert jetzt kommt der
bumerang
die zahl der korona fälle steigt
drastisch an mehr als 8.300
neuinfektionen allein am montag der
gouverneur zieht die notbremse
wir sind in der lage die ausbreitung des
virus zu unterdrücken wir haben sein
wachstum zu beginn niederschlagen können
jetzt wird uns das wieder gelingen
30.000 dollar hat jessica alice verloren
als sie ihren salon zum ersten mal
schließen musste die zweite runde wird
ihr möglicherweise finanziell das genick
brechen
die ganze welt kämpft gegen das virus
und wissenschaftler auf der ganzen welt
erforschen es auch an der uniklinik
hamburg eppendorf
nach einer neuen studie kann das virus
auch das herz befallen herzzellen
infizieren und sich darin
vermehren matthiesen hat die details es
ist eine beunruhigende erkenntnis dass
corona virus kann herzzellen befallen
der hamburger kardiologe dirk westermann
und sein team hatten gewebeproben von
menschen untersucht die an den folgen
einer kurve 19 erkrankung verstorben
waren
wir konnten zeigen dass von 39 an cupid
19 verstorbenen patienten und patienten
in der tat in etwa einem drittel das
saas kopf 2 virus auch im herzen
nachweisbar war und dort kann es sich
der studie zufolge sogar vermehren wie
sehr es das herz schädigt ist aber noch
unklar
was wir zeigen konnten ist dass es zu
einer vermehrten ausschüttung von
botenstoffen kommen die entzündung
fördern
ob das aber klinische relevanz in der
langzeit folge haben müssen weitere
arbeiten erst noch zeigen
es bräuchte reihen untersuchungen an
lebenden cupid 19 patienten so der
mediziner
gute nachrichten gab es aus der
impfstoffforschung des hamburger uni
klinikums dort beginnt schon bald eine
weitere klinische studie sahen sich
obwohl wir uns nicht beworben haben sehr
sehr viele probanden schon gemeldet über
2000 also es wird sicherlich so wie es
aussieht kein problem sein diese
studienplätze zu füllen
je mehr verschiedene impfstoffe umso
besser dass die einhellige meinung der
wissenschaft da drückt dann auch die
bundesforschungsministerin die daumen
müssen wir uns auf ein leben mit
pandemien einstellen
es hätte erfreute hat zu dieser frage
stimmen von wissenschaftlern gesammelt
wie wahrscheinlich sind pandemien was
sind die herausforderungen
zusammengestellt in unserer von der
korona krise ist auch der autozulieferer
continental betroffen
der konzern befindet sich in einem
nachfrage tief auf der virtuellen
hauptversammlung in hannover kündigte
firmenchef degenhardt einen noch
härteren sparkurs an überkapazitäten
müssten weiter verringert werden
es müssten zusätzlich mehrere hundert
millionen
euro eingespart werden konnte ich
steckte bereits vor der pandemie in
einem großen umbauprozess weltweit
könnten tausende stellen wegfallen
insgesamt arbeiten rund 240.000 menschen
bei continental neue belastungsprobe für
die britisch chinesischen beziehungen
pekings sicherheitsgesetz für die
ehemalige britische kronkolonie hongkong
sorgt schon für politische spannungen
jetzt schließt großbritannien dem
chinesischen technologiekonzern huawei
endgültig vom ausbau des 5g
mobilfunknetzes aus london folgt damit
forderungen der us-regierung die sieht
in der huawei technik ein einfallstor
für chinesische spionage essen technik
oder kleidung bei vielen produkten
lassen deutsche unternehmen auch im
ausland arbeiten stichwort
internationale lieferketten
dabei achten sie aber nicht genug auf
menschenrechte sagt die bundesregierung
und fordert jetzt besserung an einem t
shirt zum beispiel arbeiten viele mit
die baumwolle muss angebaut und geerntet
werden dann gereinigt anschließend
müssen die stoffe gewebt gefärbt
bedruckt und schließlich vernäht werden
das alles passiert an verschiedenen
orten oft unter fragwürdigen bedingungen
cornelia schiemenz wegwerf mode für den
europäischen markt produziert schnell
und billig in asien deutsche
mindeststandards soziale absicherung
arbeitsschutz fehlanzeige
eine umfrage im auftrag der
bundesregierung ergibt nun die deutsche
wirtschaft schafft es nicht ethische
prinzipien in ihren lieferketten selbst
zu überwachen und transparent zu machen
wir akzeptieren und zementieren damit
die ausbeutung von menschen natur in
entwicklungsländern und wir tolerieren
im großen stile kinderarbeit deutsche
unternehmen schieben die verantwortung
nur allzu oft und gern an die zulieferer
ab damit soll schluss sein
mittels eines sogenannten lieferketten
gesetzes sollen unternehmen gezwungen
werden überall auf der welt die
menschenrechte einzuhalten
viele unternehmen heißt das konkret dass
sie menschen rechtliche risiken in ihren
lieferketten kennen müssen
das klar sein muss wo und wie waren vor
produkte produziert werden und welche
arbeitsbedingungen auch lokale
beschäftigte haben
der bundeswirtschaftsminister von der
cdu lehnt das gesetz ab und auch die
deutsche wirtschaft läuft sturm
was wir nicht einsehen ist das
unternehmen für die taten und das
handeln dritter also für ihre
lieferanten und deren differenz in aller
welt verantwortlich gemacht werden
können diese haftung können deutsche
unternehmen nicht übernehmen
das lieferketten gesetz sollen noch in
diesem sommer auf den weg gebracht
werden koalitionsstreit nicht
ausgeschlossen
jetzt eine durchwachsene bilanz zum
straßenverkehr in deutschland einerseits
gab es im vergangenen jahr wieder mehr
unfälle
andererseits ist die zahl der toten
weiter zurückgegangen und zwar auf den
niedrigsten stand seit beginn der
statistik 2009 10 kamen insgesamt 3000
46 menschen bei verkehrsunfällen ums
leben das sind sieben prozent weniger
als 2008 zehnter gegen den trend stieg
die zahl der getöteten fahrradfahrer auf
445 auch weil mehr rad gefahren wird
jetzt zu dir norbert in berlin wird
wieder tennis gespielt profitennis
international sony sogar mit etwas
publikum aber inzwischen ganz ohne
deutsche beteiligung denn gestern am tag
eins das aus für görges für petkovic
traf und hast heute der höhepunkt der
halbfinals das duell zwischen dem
weltranglisten-dritten dominic thiem und
dem erst 18-jährigen toptalent jannik
sinne dominic thiem im weißen shirt gibt
sich in diesem halbfinale erstmal kaum
eine blöße hochkonzentriert besonders
bei seinen aufschlagspielen satzball im
ersten durchgang jannik sinne rutschte
auch noch auf sechs zu drei für den
weltranglisten dritten
der zweite satz packend umkämpft der 18
jahre alte youngster aus italien immer
wieder mit spektakulären punkten wie
diesen dann aber doch matchball für den
österreicher im tie-break jannik sinne
schlägt ins haus und dominik
steht im endspiel dieses
einladungsturniers wir haben eben
darüber geredet dass sehr seriöses das
eigentlich nur komisch charakter hat
weil jeder einfach den wettkampf will
jeder will nach so langer pause wieder
voll spielen im finale von berlin trifft
team auf einen weiteren italiener matteo
wäre teenie real madrid steht kurz vor
dem meistertitel gestern abend der 2 1
sieg beim fc granada die königlichen
jetzt zwei spieltage vor saisonende mit
vier punkten vor dem erzrivalen
barcelona und nur noch einen sieg vom 34
titel gewinnt entfernt die trainer sie
dann ist der erfolg zurückgekehrt bei
den königlichen drei jahre ohne titel
diese durststrecke scheint ein ende zu
haben
die bringt madrid beim mittelfeld club
aus granada schon nach zehn minuten in
führung der winkel zu spitz der schuss
des franzosen umso genauer auf der
tribüne mit ihm in ungnade gefallenen
wall isabel jede menge hochkaräter auf
dem platz eine menge erfahrung zb wenn
sie mal das 2 0 nach einer
dreiviertelstunde ähnliches strickmuster
auch hier ein genauer abschluss gegner
granada kann durch matschies nur noch
verkürzen durch die beine von torwart
kultur mit dem neunten sieg in folge
könnte das team um modric und groß schon
am donnerstag gegen villarreal den
titelgewinn perfekt machen
beachtlich wie oft war bayern deutscher
meister
nur 30 mal das wetter bietet morgen
einiges regen gewitter und sonne die
details hat gleich katja von eva bettina
schausten begrüßt sie um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal darin ein gespräch
mit bayerns ministerpräsident
hier übernimmt morgen petra gerster
haben sie noch einen schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das ist mal
typisches mitteleuropäisches
sommerwetter da zieht mal wieder ein
tiefer randtief yvonne mit seiner
kaltfront allerdings zieht die nur sehr
langsam bringt aber doch etwas frische
temperaturen mit heute nachts sinken die
werte am mittel- und am oberrhein bis
auf 16 grad bis auf zehn grad geht es an
der donau und am alpenrand runter denn
dort ist es meist noch klar sonst aber
fällt heute nacht regen zwischen
mecklenburg vorpommern und dem saarland
an der nordseeküste lockern die wolken
schon wieder auf bei nordwestwind und
auch morgen vormittag regnet es zum teil
noch richtig kräftig zwischen der
ostseeküste und dem oberrhein
anders sieht es am alpenrand und auch
hier richtung bayerischer wald und oder
aus da zeigt sich auch mal die sonne
das sind genau die regionen in denen des
nachmittags dann haben ersten mal
gewitter geben kann
zuvor wird es nämlich genau dort auch am
wärmsten
mit temperaturen von 23 bis 25 grad die
rund um dresden oder auch münchen
sonst liegen die temperaturen an der
küste und in norddeutschland oft nur
über 17 18 grad am rhein und westlich
davon sind es 20 bis 22 grad
der donnerstag bringt noch häufig regen
am freitag lockern die wolken von
nordwesten schon mehr und mehr auf und
der samstag wird schon wieder deutlich
wärmer
schönen abend noch